prepare to take the heathen stand and
watch out for peeping toms because it's
the feel-good movie of the year
apostle and there's much to be explained
in this video we're gonna look at some
of the little things you may have missed
as well as discuss the meaning behind
it's very ambiguous ending so grab your
Bible and blood receptacles we're in for
a bloody good ride in order to
understand the ending we must first look
at the beginning the film begins with
the ward in charge of the Richardson
estate tasking Thomas Richardson with
retrieving his kidnapped sister Jennifer
her ransom letter explains that she
waits for her Savior a subtle hint at
Thomas later becoming the savior of the
island we get a brief glimpse of
Thomas's father who's been afflicted
with Alzheimer's so he obviously can't
go the top of the fireplace reading the
power of his resurrection lies in the
touch of his sufferings a quote from the
Bible Philippians chapter 3 verses 10 to
be reborn you must suffer just like
Thomas's reborn after his sufferings he
is the christ-like figure in this story
and it's only through his death and
sacrifice can others live this notion of
suffering is also contradicted by the
Prophet Malcolm when he interrogate the
man they believe to be the infiltrator
he says I have promised you a life of
riches without the icy sting of
suffering and again when he makes the
followers recite the book of Therese the
line reads there will be no suffering on
this island joy and happiness without
suffering is exactly what a false
prophet would say on Thomas's way to the
island we see a flower petal the same
flower put in Jeremy's head as a mark of
purification those who have it have been
deemed pure we see his ticket to the
island of Ariston which if you rearrange
the letters spells deniers those who
come to the island have denied their
country and their face to follow the
goddess notice the red ink stain used by
Frank so that he would know who the man
coming to negotiate for Jennifer's
release would be when Thomas goes to
help a man so that he can steal his non
red stain pass notice the book he takes
out of his suitcase it is never too late
to mend another reference to Thomas's
tumultuous relationship with religion
one which will mend itself by the end of
the film on the boat ride to the
Island a giant storm dislodges Alam and
Thomas picks it up
lambs being symbolic and Christianity as
Christ was seen as a shepherd a
protector of the weak and then this
happens wherever they're going is not a
place for the weak the passenger says
only she decides who to give or take we
do not intervene she referring to the
goddess whom they worship but
interesting to note the word intervened
since many of the characters mainly
Quinn often intervene this is a sign of
corruption which plays a large component
in understanding the ending as Thomas
walks up the mountain toward the village
he sees what appears to be a cross
something he has disdain for but as he
reaches the top we realize it's just the
mast of a ship as he enters town he
passes a statue of the goddess who
doesn't look pleased with the town's
folk the new arrivals are given a piece
of bread and a jar used to hold blood
for the goddess of course we don't know
that yet
part of the fun of the first half of
this movie is we go into this world
knowing just as much as Thomas knows and
it's through his discoveries that we
learn how this town operates when he's
checked for lice you can hear in the
background a lady pledging her undying
devotion every drop of my blood to our
lady checking out his new digs Thomas
finds the Bible of the fidgit spinner
this is their holy book you'll notice
it's Leatherface is the same background
used in the opening credits inside we
see the word according to prophet
Malcolm it's author he's an apostle to
the goddess much like how Matthew Mark
Luke and John Jesus disciples wrote
books that appear in the Bible notice
the cyclical nature of the symbol here
as we'll see with the death of Thomas
later on there's a cycle to this force
that controls the island one of death
and resurrection as director Gareth
Evans said in explaining the ending to
be honest it's a little bit cyclical and
the way that that conversation of
politics and religion the back of all of
it it's not new it might feel timely in
the wave of what we're going through
right now but it's been the same from 30
years ago the same from 50 years ago the
same from a hundred years ago it's
something for some unknown reason that
we as a society never ever learned from
there's a little bit of that cyclical
nature circular symbols are also hidden
throughout such as here
and here on his way to church Tomas
meets Andrea prophet Malcolm's daughter
she has a red stain on her face likely
some Rouge but it's a subtle hint like
the red stain on the ticket that shall
sway from the ways of the goddess and
her father in church prophet Malcolm
gives a sermon telling them how he was a
prisoner but rough seas cast them ashore
notice the shackles here we also see a
ship masked with the words Exodus Exodus
a chapter in the Bible but also a double
meaning for his exodus from his life in
Chains there's a goddess on this island
who saved them and shows Malcolm's
tongue through which to speak he says a
very important line here how he was once
a godless man but the goddess gifted him
with wisdom and he became a believer
just like how when the goddess touches
Tamas later on and he becomes a believer
again at night Thomas witnesses the
townsfolk pouring blood into their
receptacles because Thomas doesn't know
how this cult operates so later have to
steal blood from a neighboring
receptacle as his offering it's in the
morning that we get a glimpse of
Thomas's back a giant cross branded onto
it a branding he was given in China when
he led his congregation there likely as
missionaries regardless he was a devout
follower of Christ when God didn't
intervene during his time of need
Thomas renounced his faith and took up
heroine Thomas is also the name of one
of Jesus's disciples who is also known
as doubting Thomas because he lost faith
in Christ while collecting wood Thomas
confronts Jeremy about his missing
sister and we learned that she is indeed
there but more importantly that the
crops are failing and the animals have
stopped breeding at the church the new
followers are questioned by Malcolm in
an attempt to weed out the infiltrator
they're asked to recite lines from the
book of Malcolm's something the
infiltrator wouldn't know but the
followers would he mentions the book of
Therese which is not a book found in the
Bible it is unique to this religion but
the plan is foiled when one of the lot
is found out to be a spy and is skewered
like a shish kebab
it's only through Thomas's intervention
that he stops the plot and gains
Malcolm's trust for now Malcolm throws a
party so that they can keep the
townspeople busy while they search for
the infiltrators ransom this is when we
see these spooky masks which are of the
goddess notice how similar they are to
the pitcher is found in the
cave when Thomas is caught he uses a
pool of blood to escape into a nearby
cave almost as if these underground
rivers are the veins of the island in
the cave thomas finds several distinct
drawings the first is of the goddess
tied up you can tell it's the goddess
because of the rays of light coming from
the face this effect was commonly used
by painters to symbolize religious
deities notice all the hands reaching up
to her to save them the second drawing
is of a boat the Exodus which we saw in
the flashback when prophet malcolm quinn
and frank arrived whatever god is on
this island has likely been there for a
long time repeating the cycle with new
followers or victims washing ashore
finally we see a depiction of the
sacrifice two animals with their throats
slit providing blood for the goddess
notice the flowers just like what we'll
see in the next scene when malcolm
confronts the goddess in her prison
Malcolm's pissed that she's shown
herself to another person saying that
he's gonna let her starve if they don't
have a good crop season on this island
the people don't work for the goddess
the goddess works for them it's that
dynamic that has angered her and why
nothing can grow Thomas even suspects as
much when he speaks with Andrea in this
scene we also get a glimpse of the
wicker man we don't know much about him
other than he's a devout follower likely
with the charge of guarding the goddess
he is likely a crazed townsperson
covering himself in blood and wrapping
his head and branches to show his
devotion when Andrea comes to rescue
Thomas in the cave he once again brings
up how God is suffering in quotes
Matthew 7:15 beware of false prophets
who come to you in sheep's clothing but
inwardly are ravenous wolves he's of
course referring to Andrea's father back
in the village Jeremy carves a sign for
feein from the parts of the boat they
made love him a sign fian said they put
outside their new home and we all know
how that turns out Frank tells Malcolm
that he wants out saying that this place
this community it's broken he's taking
Jeremy back to the mainland and there's
nothing Malcolm can do to change his
mind but little do Frank and Malcolm
know that Quinn has ordered the guards
to put Jeremy into the heathens stand to
be purified during the purification
scene the goddess's statue looms over
them
frowning almost as if disapproving of
what's transpired
below her and that's because she is
because the whole story here is an
allegory an allegory for how we treat
nature our planet Quinn who becomes the
real antagonist in the third act says
unlike Malcolm he'll do whatever it
takes to make sure the goddess who he
refers to as a machine keeps giving them
what they want even if that means
ripping the babies from Andrea and
Jennifer that he'll inseminate and later
feed to the goddess Quinn can represent
many things from unchecked capitalism
huge oil companies and massive pollution
which cause serious harm to our earth
but reap us massive rewards he sees the
goddess or earth as a tool to be
exploited not something to be revered in
the scene where the wicker man tries to
feed the goddess Jeremy's guts she
rejects it she doesn't want what we're
doing to it and the wicker man has to
resort to a funnel to get her to take it
down I can't help but think of fracking
mining and other things we force on the
planet for short-term gain without
thinking of the long-term consequences
whereas Quinn is big business Malcolm is
more like our society like how we know
something is wrong but are unable or in
some instances unwilling to do anything
about it it will only be when a
catastrophic event occurs like the death
of the goddess do the people see the
light and turn from their old ways and
perhaps it will take a catastrophic
event for people to take action to stop
things like climate change rising sea
levels and the increase of global
natural disasters this change can be
shown in Andrea who goes back to praying
to the Lord for her father's well-being
the townspeople are also told to grab
their Bibles when fleeing the town for
the mainland then we have Thomas the
impetus for change after escaping from
the wicker man he meets with the goddess
who calls him his son almost like mother
earth calling her child she even has
roots connected into her veins she
touches Thomas showing him how Quinn and
Malcolm captured and Exploited her a
revelation if you will and this is also
where he's transferred the power of the
goddess she asked him to set her free
and he does through fire kneeling before
her in reverence with the death of the
goddess the town descends into chaos
fire spreads throughout the village and
the townspeople make an escape for the
boats when Thomas asks where Andrea is
the woman who show
the way says may God be with you to
which he replies and also with you
through the goddess he has changed he is
a believer once more even saying in his
goodbye to Andrea for her to pray for
him as Jennifer and Andrea escape an
explosion of blood and fire rockets from
the cliff the veins of the earth
crumbling under the weight of humanity's
corruption greed and violence but even
more exceptional is what happens at the
very end
Thomas succumbing to his wounds bleeds
into the Earth causing a plant to rise
Malcom smiles as Thomas's body is taken
into the earth brutes digging into his
veins
he is the new God and the island can
start anew the cycle has started once
more but what of Malcolm's smile will he
or us as a society learn from our ways
and change for the good
or are we damned to revert again
starting the cycle once more that's the
ending of apostle I hope you enjoyed my
explanation and as always I want to hear
your comments and theories below if you
liked the vid make sure to LIKE and
subscribe I also have a Twitter account
you can follow to see when my new vids
will be coming out until next time